it's easy to get down sometimes but red  dead redemption to is looking to  brighten your spirits with its depiction  of Wild West America the trailer already  showed plenty of bright prairies and  bustling farm towns but take to CEO  Strauss Zelnick has also commented on  the game's optimism speaking first about  red dead redemption one he said we took  a different point of view which is that  very occasionally westerns capture the  imagination of the public when we  launched red dead it did and those times  were right for that and I think the  times are right for a big sprawling  optimistic view of America again and  that's not meant to be cute red dead  redemption to is slated for ps4 and xbox  one in fall 2017 we don't know much  about the game other than the release  window and that it'll have some sort of  online mode stay tuned to game squat for  more and for all the latest red dead  news you're already in the right place  you